[Music]
cavemen sharpen pieces of flint and use
them to shave their facial hair
modern man can simply go purchase a pack
of razor blades for his shaver
while several styles of shavers and
blades exist
many men believe the traditional type of
razor blade gives the closest shave of
them all
[Music]
they're paper thin yet sharp enough and
strong enough to cut through the
coarsest beard
razor blades are made from a stainless
steel strip that's a mere four one
thousandths of an inch thick
the strip first enters a punching
machine that stamps out the overall
blade shape
[Music]
these dull edged blades to be are called
blanks
at this stage of the process the
stainless steel is very soft as pliable
as paper so they now harden and
strengthen it through a four step heat
treatment process
step one they heat the blanks in a
furnace to just over two thousand
degrees fahrenheit for about thirty
seconds step two they briefly submerge
them in cold water this is called
quenching step three they chill them for
about 20 seconds in a deep cooling
chamber at a temperature of minus 58
fahrenheit all this progressively
restructures the molecules hardening the
metal however the metal becomes brittle
necessitating reheating the blanks for
20 seconds
[Music]
the now hard blanks then move through a
printer which applies the razer blade
brand name
[Music]
gas flames instantly dry the wet ink
[Music]
now it's time for the blanks to become
blades
they enter a grinding and polishing
machine within it are three grinding
stations which first sharpen the contour
then produce two super sharp cutting
edges
the blades then pass through a polishing
station that removes burrs left by the
grinding until now the blades have been
connected to each other as they exit
this machine a knife separates them
[Music]
the factory's quality control lab pulls
samples from the production line and
checks among other criteria the quality
of the grinding and geometrics of the
cutting edges then every single blade
the factory produces is examined for
cutting edge defects
technicians assemble blades in packs of
up to 800 then shine fluorescent light
on the two cutting edge sides this makes
defects visible
blades that pass this inspection are
washed with solvent to remove
contaminants
[Music]
then dried
the now pristine razor blades go into a
vacuum chamber
it draws a chromium-based coating onto
the surface rendering the cutting edges
harder and more wear resistant
next spray nozzles apply a non-stick
coating which will help the blades glide
smoothly over the skin
to adhere the coating permanently to the
blade surface they bake it on for 20
minutes at about 660 degrees fahrenheit
[Music]
quality control technicians test samples
again this time to ensure the blades
meet strength specifications
this test machine measures the force
required for the blade to cut a thick
white of wet paper to a certain depth
[Music]
back in production workers submerged the
razor blades in organic oil for about
half an hour this provides additional
protection against corrosion
on the packaging line the equipment
wraps each blade individually in wax
paper
[Music]
the wax coating on the paper helps
protect the razor blade against
corrosion during storage
wax paper is also stronger than regular
paper so the blade's razor-sharp edges
don't cut through it
the edge of these razor blades are about
10 times thinner than a human hair
a blade typically lasts about six shaves
so the average male goes through quite a
few considering that over the course of
his lifetime he'll have spent more than
3 300 hours shaving his face
[Music]
you